Starting with this first equations up
here, we see that we have 3x+4 equals
smiley face. 3x has a 3 in it, but this is
multiplied by x. A term like this, even
though there is a number in it, is called
a variable term. Because its whole value
is going to change or vary depending on
what number we plug in for x. This is
definitely a variable term, 4 is just a
number so no check there and finally, we
have a smiley space. That means, it must
be a variable. And we can go through the
other three equations in the same way
turn-by-turn to figure out what should be
checked. And know that there are some
things down here that we haven't talked
explicitly about yet, and that might have
thrown you off. Like, we have a fraction
right here and we have a couple of
expononents, but we'll get to those things
pretty soon. And understanding the
difference between variable and
nonvariable terms is really important for
understanding everything that we're going
to do in Algebra. That means we're off to
a great start in developing our
foundation.